the time also to an outfit I thank you
for this full cooperation
there will be a football match this weekend
which will give rise to more
confrontation but it will be on the
sports field not on the political field
I now come to the advice
European,
you know, it was a European Council
with a lot of serious and
difficult dossiers on the agenda for some of them,
but there was also a
dossier which was not on the agenda but
which required a debate and I  I
actually decided to open the debate
on the situation of lgbt y more in connection
with legislation in hungary this summer
a debate that was difficult it was a
debate that at times was tough
but it was a debate that was also
necessary and it was a debate around the
thil there is also emotion because it
was a debate which touches on the intimacy
of convictions in connection with the
conception that we have for
each other of freedoms  fundamental and
that is why  e this file and this debate
was absolutely essential, it was
also certainly an opportunity to
make sure that we could listen to
each other and that the first one was
Hungarian could also hear the
convictions expressed by many
colleagues around  the table I have
the opportunity to recall the principle of
the European rule of law which makes this
European project the primacy of European law
and also to note the commitment to an
approach from the commission in
connection with  this situation
I also hope that the conference
on the future of europe will be a
useful opportunity to advance one's
convictions as to
fundamental freedoms as to the
fundamental values which are the cement of this Europ
an project which is above all a human
adventure  who brings us together who
brings us together is pointed m having to
go back to the future finally i come
now to the different points
you we discussed i will be building
fast for some d  between them
because you have access to the conclusions of
our meetings opportunities flight in switzerland
antonio guterres is so
important to me now of all ears fm
with riffs maybe from multiverse
on the boards in the best way in
adults with the voice  the global
challenge of death of the world
today
ok young people all where the woman does
not turn from ship it would you do you
and we intend to spend the very strong
parts of fip opportunities
everything must this mini topix this global
challenge is like  climate change
l'acavite night in night out of course in
short yes yes is on the ground and carries unity
touré must are already for the dachshund
challenge ms. del egg laying jean
dotto disc covin nineteen hundred and
changes view his boots 10th pandemic
yes beckoned  then he wears an
eight-bed break first one mobility
president possible to coordinate luca
perris especially when we bare buttocks or
variance and miou-miou times
it's a typical international
s  olidarity where it is said opportunities in
the past where a woman has commitment
signal of all monsters 8 effective
he held on the soil of haiti hand and
creation of gasoline lines
lowering report post of thebaux the lease of
the mission 10  important your soul and
interesting strike startin' pop n
wyss two slovenians a hold of a shrink or a
hue all vacant titans 2 to bill
hibble by the end of the year to try to
be my clown quiz ouattara to deliver
boss destroys a word  quickly on the
issue of migration and the debate
was not very long on this subject in the
room by the debate had been prepared
by our teams by the ambassadors
who worked we were able to quickly
agree on  operational conclusions
the idea is to focus it is true
mainly on the
external dimension of
the european union is to ask the
commission for a representative to work
on extremely concrete proposals
at the d  part of the identification
of priority countries of countries of origin
and countries of transit for which we
want to use all the
instruments at our disposal at
European level but also with our
Member States for some of them
involved in this  subject and then we
had the opportunity over dinner
to address international issues
I am not very long on the issue
of Turkey I think the bear or there
will not be more detailed on this subject there
we adopted  conclusions on
belarus conclusions on ethiopia
on the sahel on libya and if there are
questions naturally we succeed we
will react to the questions that are asked
there was a discussion again
on russia and that was the  opportunity
after a debate which was a debate of
great quality a month ago at the last
European Council to try to take a
step forward and to clarify the way in
which we want to consider the implementation
of the five principles q  who,
in our view, are the basis of the relationship with russia
we reaffirmed the importance of
implementing the implementation agreements
we also reaffirmed our
commitment to take sanctions
whenever necessary and to
consider the various options in
terms of restrictive measures
the importance also of being committed to
very committed 2d people to two people contacts
with Russian civil society
and of supporting our values in terms of funda
ental rights as usual, we have been doing regul
rly throughout the l
st months and years  we
also reiterated our commitment to
the eastern partnership
and moreover we will have an eastern partnership summit before the end of
the year
which will be organized we
also discussed the modalities and
conditions for the political dialogue
with
the  russia is of course I will come back to
this subject if he wants to say questions in
connection with the this morning wijsmans link
houlette des opportuni  tees to discuss
channels maker louis pinton receives auto
f268 of the eurozone john porter new
soul dbait microsoft gold is money was
clearly tf1 fault look in the views
of savings challenge is what the
strength wata de stone decision to
back down since just positive done
to be visible also from top was united
traditionally if we
match 2 to be strong and it will be able to
strength in it lacked for ten months in
concrete will all be tinted from the area we
say audren 8 eb yes from tibet this was
opportunity for all of leads to
express views of the primitives a braid
initials view swiss pascal to
register steen lagarde
here in brief in any case as much
as possible
the summary is of course we
will be at your disposal to
react to the questions asked in  his
matches in the heart of new york
the synergies of 50 points
hewlett affected
highco title i'm in which has been
rallye no36 member states are connected
getting vaccinated was  n 2 for all of
9 9% ifoam wind turbine of os bada souillac
side of the overtime during every
two years
the steps are necessary and talks
to world of you look at you ceo of alter
way and death by now two dominant  one
night in progress in use in date to date
yes six vaccination dates project
dabo vaccination vaccination modalities
beat stage to we need to stay
violent winnie all your truths
[Music]
and look lessons learned am and since we
let me go tropical everything  economic causes
go to 2 to play music
republic mouse
gaming critics
save october the script
flexibilization clause yufang of estate in the
middle equity at first look all
beings h notes and we have no twenty four
nage  90
his method must doses
prove to i want internal because i have
been next
al badri a fast of course and a half
dollars
the indian economy prohibits end of the
man gooch in france proves ready to go
and qatar  one of the halls include
significance of fate of
target au plan ce mid offshore dream the
stone age of x men show the youth
employment m6 channel and ipod touch of
the next next few weeks and we are ready
to des spurs
because we have learned about  failed this
program would have said last weekend
very successful we have been used in
extenso your hands up in using the enemy
movement or 2.53 pictures kinder winter
kate madden siemens de se pointer we
haven't seen this match wister who
suffers from it topic  of refuge
christensen original know we all
are told surya tropical se refuge
hindery jean claude ribaut continued
sporting turkey thing but would get
fiji and 19 tender's indridason
conflict collections
in this to protect the refugees and
supporters but she very difficult
economic times df oh yes oh yes
[Music]
choquette des chenaux organic fruits
niautou this portrait refugees in turkey and the
twenty twenty four and at the
economic soyaux mill is doing everything refugee
no more this match
anne desplaines pure imagination and
perspectives provide all point
to a telephone
all go to rfi jean jacques 3
redemption of id we agree on united 'long
term' on tiji copine approach based on
the world
great thou prospects  et foutraque the
public channel al we have position of
strength because if you look at the
iconic relationship management of good
dabi ifop and opinionway particles at the
caté weavers mmorpg big three at the cage
founder 100% of dimes porte tout
redemption balance likely to grow archer
economist  and breaks the ears
montreal last but not least and charles
this fringe of this notting
hill carnival american lover ancient articles
all of our pin political treaty noted
fruit of adverse non-discrimination 10
ha at the foundation and louisville
vapes
all say night light last  weekend and
mostefa this very customers win like in
the world in the room of al wyg defender
value because you [ __ ] you need of
v  arious russians in the union
valussi president crisis in crisis like
that of the heyritz is very soft for the
central throughout the six games girlfriend of the
board between two missions or
nas or mat of diversion is of the type
of gide in question or consciously gide
council me his popular restaurant
whose presidential are false it's just
vegetable represents a
fundamental precondition that of the plan
observes since his spouse of 2.6 snow
there to be the master of the just and
creative torrent that s opens to ss murder
their shares to  czechs in a shelter
at the same mouse problem international
sinh hùng regions of the world or that
now i know village
for vaud ticino sign his product of
young people europe orders in front of
officials of our seasonal workers
we have withdrawn and a
better duration john duncan kovacs  that
wireless mouse and top doubs in the world
handmade for three years and I
deserved mahmoud interior loan concluded
from  isère lived again was my surprise if he
said m
leers generation y or throughout studies
or internship but in red international
jacques fernique is searchable sheep
and who asks for finds like or
dragged diapers that where
starting missions that of q7 v6 2.7  stadium
even jean what to pay after
research national plan of a
presidential blow to the open gardens
to be I feel European
the article 5 themes it is also to
propose them a Slovenian
we press to say very nice week of
fine it will be a special conditions
hopes is probable and he dares mothers
courage for three tops squaring of the
trial we will accomplish qiushi ready to
compete
we think that are forgotten the front
vercoutre but it is a promising father
charles troesch punch difficult match and
yet all my program and not to
the do
or council unit mission of the nist
recovered for the province diplomats and
disposable bottles
we observe still practiced as
mental  from pouilloux to the fight you have
crisis and that rescued a transition of
surfaces crisis paref economic cooperation
now these cuts that the
receipts just the prices arises that
vern said romaine goupil and social
d'oignons had paid that tv nasim
social aid door or mahmoud  intent but
it is above all our concrete action ready
to sign all the best and country
leave remove these don't they have and
I ask the parliamentarians they
apply to the council tell us that
they understand touch that we are
masters of thrillers
while now of a directive that
has gone up a little serious is under pressure
and that is a social would plot shrink
tax onions to spot
and shoot them
or when I beat report that
social economy by a smile  almost part
of a single map pressured
unfinished gervais build stadiums
concerns us allows us to spot ahead
the european climate that made to
be even terr  history and which
allow us these rumors continue times
communism or vallecano tauriac
chronicle in 2050 and which won in
writing its president not to forget that
all play it all for a reason suite
for fifty-five of the simpsons co2 emissions
and finally drink their cost
digital pressure which shows without
just wear gently
updated after that we are still shown
signs of hamdi cherifi
fresh capital premiums was back on
stage giving shape and mills practice
under the coat and monkeys all
members status  there is mr pay and may 11
at space georges plunder hours of
lessons but free but run floor by a
deer or tibetan saturn pardini misery
is named for 320 obligation for
submarine fiber optic cable between europe
and south america
coca  mud and open water and where and when
I feel back better
skills discussed gardens to
seasonals who put downs other
circuit 21  Ivorian soldiers but who
great instrument mounted the bonuses
and between June 12 and only took
a break and about thirty in the comerica
routine there is europe private
actua film without throwing rare
ministers such as from europe distorted
company at the  autumn affirms its corridor
of trees tour of europe in the world 2009
coach like the injections by
nash acted like in the pacific casino
yves jacolot leaves smiled not even
looked so bad from rhdp players to the
guests a muscle or indians
stuffing us  everything including but you play
who played Wednesday April 6 at 8 p.m. at the
narita marie space of the climate or who slam
and 1.2 against 7.1 gip remains interested
in this tour of europe has promised a
bath through currencies  in august
cover regions more very immigrants that
's more common from seventy
first from pro rhdp to
educational proverb bluecar
key first cry to
human resources legal immigration channel what
reports six teams are often  by
a company 06 mn build
conclude that at the 1st of rest or even
from father christian d'agen it is a pie
xii hugh jackman date of the council
tmz a good rhythm 10 h guilty m p o and
om ni conviction that that won
necessary firm hennessey  gousseau
also ok mine they rot or
discover this second tour of europe for
france-eire tell us we in the jerseys of the
real fly is a showman jodie
from europe
I'm waiting for the primaries his audience yesterday
the apse and are we  precious on the
reputation which is fundamental that we
see a concern for the black tea angel
worn by politiken hakim than his show
with omens but for m franck saved
important it is the defender are
more to give a benchmark an
operation and a guarantee of the
spectrum  stage it is usually given
at tambacounda you were doing opens as
a prohibited practice of our union
was born an ordinary communion mesh
internal control shift or poorly
communicated and our universe
of l  'other they are struggling this union that
maintains play a role other train
of roasting extractor of any concern of
the angel direct size
direct shaw of the cords cohort the other
more work than you have nothing
concrete doors to berthe yu chi  ming
is green and nursery rhymes already feels the
presidency was returning images norway my
dear charles
I thank you from my heart for all the
cooperation we have had during these six
months wish you include strong match to
see very close and future cooperation
yes without hesitation in front  christophe
hutteau the schmitz sisters and few days
thanks to the
soc 28 contest or decided to rest of ten beasts
and lips the eyes when they
live in oswald used end of metal value
at and age of the unit was not possible
to do can back 2  value cndd at stop
and internet of twihome for right by
a smooth world all yes finally of crem
also of the european law of premium if they
offer of youpine velious inwi is 20.8
in wax sometimes you know it's the  view
it at gentle arguments since
these opportunity for many leader all
a woman of wines history commitments
ff12 fundamental value is important to
fight for us to protect various year
is 28.7 in commission title in new
haven where stands the blur
of  importance ignored everything and robust
stone the institution night watch
destroyed implement the daily life of
fundamental principle the state of bezy strong
discipline project pivot highest
paid star 5 and her rich lands firecrackers
pratikadent there is she ignores from where
loach is played off new york times
there had been hit progress is
expected at mahjong detour of two laps
of circuit in europe
wen jun would have said 10 years left
us from a hole to forgive them in
europe m
the record  from umbria tons of salt
i put 5% black metal/fabric know
advise us from her darling doug at 16.2
hearing from hungary it's a sign if the
greens
i maybe have pretty waves as well
as  two tips  they communal quarry
affirmative to consider that they violate
permanent metadata of our
elimination brother he narrates a range
the 16 million households of
easy match but lionel good grades azdn in
europe to this group i own you is
complete a range mathias doing
freiheit und  there are 100 aromas of kate
between democrats and anti-democrats in
line honda steve is issued the ben disont
on the democracy and aozora out of
hospitals new drug mart piece i'm sixty
charity fund for democracy and is magic
flight denial fine site web du bst dit
democratic two rare hospitals we
are fast food in barbery line of
things we have to be discriminated against we said no
young torn off 2 is discriminating
hines was democratic open and
emitting groans 2010 and batteries
supply the usa where he joined de
weiterswiller we fight alone  of this type
and will be absolutely only solid and
democratic
madam nick swisher and social in africa like
this match yes of mr pouti  don't saturday 22 19
years old president michèle and spock minister
poutine three matches our
cause needs 9th position vis-à-vis uk or a
few months you have to know looks like it
together before lying at war
we will train thank you maybe first
a word on the ass on russia first
i repeat that the very thorough debate
we had a month ago was the
basis for trying to clarify
in unity in the strength of unity the
principles at the outset hold  we
want to consider the future of this
relationship with russia
and I would have farted once again that
we strongly condemn all
disruptive activities is illegal by
russia and reaffirm once again that
our
compass is the five principles but
simply we have  considered in the
context of the debate a month ago that we
did not simply react when we
were provoked or attack we must
have an ambition to act more
proactively to promote our values
end our interests  are and therefore to
give more operational content
to these five principles and this is what
was done in the case of the meeting
that took place last night what are
its commitments 1 was repeated that
the implementation  of the miss agreements is
a fundamental condition to
allow a possible lack an
ingredient change of attitude
european union vis-à-vis russia 2
is to consider that far from being committed
not only with words or
declarations but with  actions to
support robust institutions in
the eastern partnership countries and to
strengthen the capacity for cooperation
between the european union and all
of these countries in seven of these countries 3 this
is the idea that we must strengthen
resilience, including the
European Union's ability to resist in
key sectors when there are
hybrid threats when there are cyber
attacks it is clear that there is a
need to strengthen the robustness of
the European Union and its
member states on these subjects, and then the
five principles mention the possibility,
when there are subjects of mutual interest,
of considering cooperation with
russia, it was actually no longer
precise by putting examples of themes
such as the  climate,
the environment,
health, certain topics of
police safety linked to safety for which
we must be able to consider a dialogue and
in a very very logical way
we have invited who we should also, in
the case of the European Council, explore the
different modalities  and conditions
to ensure that this dialogue can
be more structured from the street, otherwise
this was the commitment that was
made and I confirm that
since taking office on several
occasions I have been able to talk to
directly with the tithe poutine to
express the positions of the
european union to defend our interests and
also to report to the members of
the european council and we will  ir
together
but how on each of the
points we can implement
implement these principles which form
our compass a slip test
sequencing in date coordination invoice
be a progress
one love and teach beats
european moustoir ue union 10th league 2
valves will have beautiful group  trod vaccinate
all sold at abomey prefecture it
is therefore a question of a departure of jurassians
would save jurrjens decor that I slept
instructions of the rhdp or sabotage
destiny says the German
the airlines is my TV of
course of 102 between these two  third of our
meals and that hervé pays these ruins the
same for the 14 monkey lions to the one
that judges would make public at bhl
review of everything necessary and
conscience therefore advises us not
subscribed that it to have to reopen
conditions  unworthy tradition that forum
des aces and the college of quaestors at the
level of the various parties nick
swisher at marriage or pina freedom
for the payment of UFOs poses d  are
steps the five questions
they want like dsk the young people of
disney or snes of ubisoft mszp yuko of
last margin of a site nintendo ds
verisign sétif topic incredible force with
their date with all of course
10:09
she accepts
two state 'solution' massachusetts  eye
center are both presidents
are we all close to this one
coming from the
senate note that nick swisher and saint jean
count jean the context
yes hello jean count the context I have
a question is that am I suffering
the lessons to be drawn from the crisis that empty
you indicated that the file was
discussed is what it is
specific subject like to mention all
health all the internal market economy
are general and you
specified knows the prowess of  the
commission was rather well received
does that mean that they will be
put in place quickly I am thinking for
example of the epidemic the
chief epidemiologist or the annual reports collection
proposes is what it is a  n fact it
will not be put in place quickly
thank you it was indeed a request
from the council that broke down a few months ago that
the commission be able to present a
first document a pure a first
report on the lessons to be learned from the
pandemic
the distribution has essentially turned
on the aspect linked to health in
crisis situations and how to
learn lessons in order to be able to cooperate
more quickly coordinated more
quickly and in a more effective
and efficient manner and indeed a
desire to act quickly insofar as this
will be  one of the priorities of the
Slovenian presidency, the formal launch of which will take place
this evening in Slovenia with the ambition
before the end of the year to return to the
level of the European Council with this theme
to give impetus so that we
can progress and  make
more formal decisions on the subject
indeed and d'oise and
50 economic tenants by an
order if i dat report to me had to
take one last question  by
christian spillmann afp christian yes
hello
i hope you see you can hear me
i have two questions first and
on russia
mr michel in the current context
of positions within the european union
is it wise to propose
asking for a summit with vladimir
poutine
in fact it gives the image of a
torn union mrs merkel is disappointed she
left the summit yesterday expressing
her disappointment and finally the
european union gives poutine's game which
is to say I choose who are my
interlocutors with whom I speak and I
do not speak my second question is
more specific and I would like to come back
to hungary with a direct question
to michel and madam von der leyen
sir costa east something  which
was very important
he said that the european union
could not accept people who did
not respect the values
stion is simple do you think that vikto
orban today
if he does not cha  nge this law
still its place around the council table
because we are going to launch an
infringement procedure everyone knows that it
takes time and that in fact it is a
kind of
dole victory which will be exploited by  all the
populists in the european union who are
going to show up in the next
elections to challenge the rule of
european law to challenge the
values of the european union and that is a
isaster so be
clear say yes mr viktor orban
if he
continue like this has no place
and then how do we do since
indeed we can not exclude
ask that it's another problem
no - clearly say thank you first on the
on the first question in relief from
russia I  I have already answered on the subject
I want to reaffirm that the debate
is not a weakness on the contrary
the debate is once a week the
debate is the guarantor of the capacity
to be in European unity and then
I  love you a little surprised
the way the question was posed
because a few days ago there was
a summit between joe biden and
president vladimir putin and was not
interpreted as being a sign of
weakness which is legitimate only at
European level when we  wants to
implement principles that we believe are
fundamental to consider another
relationship with russia we can be
more concrete and more operational and
no one has asked for
a meeting tomorrow at 27, that is to say putin
was not  that at all which were on
the table
at no time on the other hand if you are
actually affected in an
extremely well balanced way well balanced
it is a firmness I say them on
certain principles but
also an ability and under conditions to engage a
dialogue and to reflect together
European Council on the most
appropriate end of the dialogue which must be able to
be carried out to defend our values
end our interests that is the subje
t and I can tell you that  e to
have been present with the colleagues
in the room we had a debate which made it
possible to note a very strong unity
at the same time on the objectives and on the
ways of approaching our
objectives that is that the approach is finally
on  the other question we have already had
the opportunity to answer it seems to
me I reaffirmed that it is
indeed fundamental to show
that we do not close our eyes that we do
not lower our eyes and at the  on the contrary
it was eye to eye that a
debate took place between 27 Heads of State and
Government who represent their countries
around the table of the European Council
it is the functioning of the institutions
will sometimes remind the European Council
of  not to address the issue of
fundamental values to look
way it's
ecause we're doing and it's becau
e we've done and the wish I expre
sed at the end of the meeting is there it's
that viktor orban is heard and
listened carefully to the points of view
of the arguments  ents and then effectively this ability in the case of the European rule of law to ensure that the procedures work to enforce the treaties and especially those which were at the heart of this project these fundamental values article 2 which was in particular destroyed by gold underlines a few moments the native of good seconds at this point i turn democracy is quite empty emma in kyiv nutrition of the children of the drummers form soul sits in 2000 from april 2010 the departure we were engaging um die welt we are in democracy no euros single pass horse and dialogue after argumentative to threats wendel reichstadt prime time followed by a relapse in doha we come management of the school descartes enrique lifelong work at a reichstadt system annoyance with the gold mechanism not enough that i am a bird art nar is going to be an owl and sit in brief that chic you want above all a range is what you are going to be chosen bankruptcy life what is it
that a clause after this comfort of the
tenants of the keys of this final
thank you so this work